>>> FIRST, BREAKING NEWS JUST IN
ABOUT THE FEDERAL CASE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, THE FEDERAL JUDGE
GRANTING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
REQUEST FOR A THIRD PARTY TO
REVIEW THE MATERIAL THE FBI TOOK
UNDER SEARCH WARRANT FROM HIS
MAR-A-LAGO HOME.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO EVAN
PARIS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW?
>> DONALD TRUMP GOT A BIG, BIG
BREAK FROM THIS JUDGE EILEEN CAN
WHO SAYS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS TO STOP USING THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE RETREEZED
FROM MAR-A-LAGO LAST MONTH.
WHAT SHE'S SAYING IS THERE'S AN
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY REVIEW
THAT CAN CONTINUE BUT FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION, THEY CAN NO
LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
DOCUMENTS WHILE THIS SPECIAL
MASTER DOES ITS REVIEW.
JUST TO REMIND PEOPLE, THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE THIS IS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS LEGAL
TEAM WAITED ABOUT THREE WEEKS,
AND THEN THEY MADE THIS REQUEST
TO THIS JUDGE TO ASK FOR THIS
THIRD-PARTY LAWYER TO COME IN
AND REVIEW THESE DOCUMENTS.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T TRUST THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE FBI TO
DO THIS FAIRLY.
THEIR CHIEF ISSUE IS WITH THE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE
MATERIAL, WHICH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BY THE WAY, SAYS IS
AN ISSUE, AND THEY ALREADY HAVE
A SPECIAL TEAM THAT HAS ISOLATED
ABOUT 500 PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
THAT THEY SAY COULD, COULD BE
PART OF THIS ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE ISSUE.
BUT RIGHT NOW THE JUDGE SAYS
NONE OF THAT MATTERS.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE COME IN AND ESSENTIALLY
LOOK OVER THE SHOULDER OF THE
FBI, OF THE PROSECUTORS TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING THAT SHOULD
BE REMOVED IS REMOVED.
RIGHT NOW WHAT THIS MEANS, JOHN,
AT LEAST FOR NOW, THERE'S A
DLAGS IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> AT LEAST FOR NOW A DELAY IN
THE INVESTIGATION.
LET'S BRING IN KARA SCANNELL IN
AS WELL.
THE JUDGE GAVE BOTH SIDES UNTIL
NEXT WEEK TO COME UP WITH A
PROPOSAL FOR HOW THIS SPECIAL
MASTER WILL WORK OUT.
THE DELAYS -- WE DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG -- WILL DELAY THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE DOCUMENTS.
>> THIS WILL DELAY THE REVIEW.
THEY'LL HAVE UNTIL FRIDAY TO
COME UP WITH A LIST OF
CANDIDATES.
THAT BEGINS THIS PROCESS.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER SPECIAL
MASTER CASES IS THE REVIEW CAN
TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY A
LENGTHY DELAY IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THERE WOULD LIKELY BE A DELAY
ANYWAY BECAUSE OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND THE DOJ POLICY.
BUT IT WILL SLOW DOWN THIS
REVIEW.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE OFTEN
DISPUTES THAT HAVE TO BE SETTLED
BY THE SPECIAL MASTER.
IT'S CERTAINLY GOING TO, YOU
KNOW, REALLY SLOW THIS DOWN AND
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK AT THE 11,000
PAGES OF DOCUMENTS THAT THEY
PICKED UP IN THE SEIZURE AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
I MEAN THE JUDGE ALSO IN THIS
RULING NOTING THAT SHE, YOU
KNOW, FOUND THAT CASTING SOME
DOUBT ON THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE
FBI, SHE THOUGHT IT DID SHOW
HARM.
THAT'S WHY SHE WAS GRANTING THE
REQUEST FOR A SPECIAL MASTER,
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVEN'T HAD
SPECIAL MASTERS REVIEW EXECUTIVE
ISSUES, CERTAINLY SIDING WITH
TRUMP, GIVING HIM THIS
SHORT-TERM VICTORY IN THIS
INVESTIGATION, JOHN.
>> LET'S BRING IN THE FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR JENNIFER
ROGERS.
TO KARA'S POINT, JUDGE CANON IS
REJECTING THE VIEW OF THE DODGE.
DONALD TRUMP NO LONGER HAS
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THE JUDGE HERE DOESN'T SAY HE
DEFINITELY DOES, BUT IT'S AN
OPEN QUESTION AND IT SHOULD BE
EXPLORED.
SHE ALSO WRITES MAKING THE CASE
FOR A SPECIAL MASTER.
SHE SAID THE INVESTIGATION OF
THE TREATMENT OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT IS IN THE UNIQUE
INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY.
JUDGE CANON SAYING SLOWING DOWN
HERE IS GOOD FOR EVERYBODY.
YOU MADE THE POINT IN A
CONVERSATION LAST WEEK YOU
THOUGHT THIS WAS OUT OF BOUNDS.
WHAT NOW?
>> WELL, I STILL THINK IT'S
LEGALLY UNJUSTIFIED JOHN,
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
SHOW IRREPARABLE HARM.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A CASE WHERE
IT'S BEEN UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY THINGS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOES IS
CRIMINALLY INVESTIGATE PEOPLE,
SO THE NOTION THAT CAN ESTABLISH
IRREPARABLE HARM TO ME STILL
SAYS THIS IS A LEGALLY WRONG
DECISION.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE FACT THAT
SHE'S GRANTING IT BECAUSE HE'S
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS GOOD
NEWS FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
IT SETS A PRECEDENT FOR OTHER
DEFENDANTS DOWN THE ROAD SAYING,
HEY, WAIT A MINUTE, YOU SEARCHED
MY STUFF AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S
NOT MY LAWYER'S OFFICE.
I THINK THAT PIECE IS GOOD.
I ALSO THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A SILVER LINING IN THAT I
DON'T THINK THERE WILL BE A LOT
OF ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENTED FOUND.
IT WOULD ONLY PERTAIN IF
DOCUMENTS WERE CREATED IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND SO MANY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE BEEN
CREATED OTHER PLACES.
WHILE IT SLOWS THINGS DOWN,
WHICH IS BAD FOR THE DOJ AND
THEIR CASE, I THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE A LOT OF SPECIAL DOCUMENTS
PULLED BY THE MASTER.
>> IN SOME PARTS THIS IS UNFAIR,
BUT DO WE HAVE ANY INDICATION,
ANY REPORTING THAT SUGGESTS THAT
THE JUDGE HAD LEANED IN, SAYING
SHE WAS LIKELY TO DO THIS.
WOULD THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TRY
TO APPEAL THIS OR FIGHT IT IN A
HIGHER COURT OR EAT THEIR PEAS
IF YOU WILL.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE HEARD IS
FOR THEM TO ASK THE JUDGE
SPECIFICALLY.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
AS JENNIFER POINTS OUT, THIS
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS A STRANGE
ONE.
IT'S NEVER BEEN FOUGHT OVER IN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S
GOING TO END UP AND WE DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO GO
TO THE SUPREME COURT BEFORE
WE'RE ABLE TO MOVE ON.
KARA MIGHT HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
THAT.
>> TO EVAN'S POINT, PROSECUTORS
LAST WEEK WERE SAYING THEY
WANTED SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY APPEAL.
THEY DIDN'T SAY THEY WOULD
DEFINITELY DO SO.
I THINK PART OF THAT WOULD
DEPEND ON THE CONTOURS OF THIS
ORDER THAT JUST CAME DOWN
MOMENTS AGO.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT DOJ SAID
QUITE FIRMLY IN THE HEARING IS
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS NO
CLAIMS OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
HERE AND THEY REALLY ARGUED IT.
NOW THAT THIS ESSENTIALLY GIVES
TRUMP THE WIN HE WANTED AND
ENJOINS THEIR INVESTIGATION,
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE HOW THE DOJ
RESPONDS HERE.